[Music]
take two balloons and suspend one of
them in the air by means of thread hold
the other balloon by a thread tied to
its end and bring it near the other
balloon which is suspended what do you
notice do you see any force between them
nothing in particular now rub the free
balloon which is in your hand with a
woollen cloth for some time after that
bring it again near the suspended
balloon do you see anything strange now
yes both the balloons seem to be coming
towards each other we can say that they
are attracting each other why is this
happening now it's happening because of
the force that acts between them the
force is attractive in nature but this
attractive force was not present
initially before rubbing something must
have happened to this balloon after we
rubbed it with a woolen cloth we can say
that this balloon acquired something
from the cloth after rubbing and that
something is what we call electrostatic
charge
let me repeat when we rub the balloon
with a woolen cloth it acquires some
charge so this balloon is charged now
and this charge is responsible for the
force of attraction between the two
balloons what about the suspended
balloon we call it the uncharged balloon
since it has no charge it does not have
any charge as we have interrupted with
anything now rub the suspended balloon
also with a woolen cloth it will also be
charged so we have two charged balloons
now bring them together what did you see
now both the balloons are moving away
from each other now that is they are
repelling each other again they are
repelling each other because of the
force that is acting between them but
here the force is repulsive in nature
what can we conclude from these two
experiments in the first case there was
a force of attraction between the
charged and the uncharged body and the
second case there was a force of
repulsion between both
just bodies in fact whenever we rub two
bodies together both of them acquire
charge then discharge attracts or repels
other charged or uncharged bodies when
brought near them the force exerted by a
charged body on another charged or
uncharged body is known as electrostatic
force the electrostatic force can be
either attractive or repulsive in nature
we will study more about electrostatic
charges in our other videos now I want
you to answer a question for me
if electrostatic force a non-contact
force or not yes it is a non-contact
force we thought that contact was not
required for the balloons to move away
or come towards each other here is one
more experiment that you can perform at
home rub your hair with the corn for
some time and then drink this comb your
small pieces of paper what do you see
the small pieces of paper get attracted
to the comb why are they attracted to
disco can you tell me the reason for
this when you rub your hair with the
coat it acquires some
electrostatic charge and this charge was
responsible for the electrostatic force
of attraction between the small pieces
of paper and the pole
[Music]